lady gaga is keeping it real about the
mental toll her latest role took on her
i don't consider myself a particularly
ethical person
but i'm fair
that's gaga playing patrizia reggiani
the italian woman who served 18 years of
a 26-year prison sentence for having her
ex-husband maurizio gucci killed at
least it's my name sweetie
our name
sweetie maurizio was the grandson of the
original founder of the gucci fashion
empire now gaga is opening up in the
december issue of british vogue about
just how challenging that transformation
was admitting that she went so deep into
the role that she started to lose touch
with reality quote i had some
psychological difficulty at one point
towards the end of filming i was either
in my hotel room living and speaking as
reggiani or i was on set living and
speaking as her gaga also shares a story
about going for a stroll one day during
filming explaining quote i hadn't taken
a walk in about two months and i
panicked i thought i was on a movie set
worth
style power
who wouldn't care for that
yes even when cameras weren't rolling
gaga still acted like reggiani the oscar
winner says she spent nine months living
with an italian accent and spent a year
and a half living in character 24 7.
telling the mag quote off camera i never
broke i subscribe to
unconventional punishments
as for shedding the character once the
film wrapped gaga says that was tough
quote i remember when we started filming
i knew i had become and i knew that the
greater challenge was going to be
unbecoming i haven't really been able to
fully process that you know it's one of
those things you just never know what's
going to happen house of gucci marks
gaga's second leading role in a feature
film the first how could we ever forget
[Music]
that song shallow earned gaga her first
oscar for best original song in her film
a star is born moments after taking home
the golden statue gaga was overcome with
joy speaking with e.t i'm so happy what
does it mean to you to know that for the
rest of your life oscar winner goes in
front of your name more than you could
ever understand
all it takes is to believe in yourself
and i just hope that
people
all over the world tonight know that if
you believe in you and you love yourself
and you put your mind to it you can do
anything